the day has finally come for me to step
out of my comfort zone and take on a
challenge that according to my most
recent Twitter poll has specifically
stopped over 75% of people from even
attempting it because it's so damn big
one piece the magnum opus of one Monica
Ichiro Oda since 1997 this man has been
spending what I can only assume is every
waking hour of his life drawing this
manga series because as I'm running this
video there are almost one thousand
chapters available to read this man has
dedicated his life to this story and so
in order for me to even stand a chance I
need to throw caution to the wind to
bring a manga every single place I go
and I need to tell my girlfriend I love
her because I won't be seeing her for
the next five months I know nothing
about this series I have never in my
life watched a single episode or read a
single chapter of the story I am a
simple Dragon Ball fan exploring for the
very first time the most popular and
curvy shounen jump manga of all time
more popular than Naruto more popular
than Gaga 13 even more popular than
Dragonball this is my first impression
of the greatest high seas adventure
manga has to offer today I review Eiji
rodas modern epic one piece
in this video I will be reviewing the
beginning of one piece of story all the
way to the end of the barity arc which
takes us about 68 chapters into the
manga what can I say the journey of a
thousand miles starts with the first
step and my adventure starts now
oh also I'll be reading the manga and
for my editors sanity he'll be using
corresponding footage from the anime
enjoy romance dawn chapters 1 to 7 the
series begins in what I believe to be a
fantastic fashion we are shown the last
king of the Pirates meeting his end Gold
Roger with his last words acting as a
challenge to the rest of mankind to find
his legendary treasure the fabled one
peace
tidal drop a new age of piracy kicks off
and that's when we are introduced to
Luffy our main character as a small
child literally stabbing his eye in the
middle of a tavern full of pirates to
earn their respect alright so the
promise of legendary pirate treasure and
now our main characters first action is
to stab himself in the face to earn
street cred this story sure knows how to
grab your attention and to set up a goal
right off the bat in this tavern
immediately after Luffy's introduction
we're introduced to a colorful cast of
pirate characters led by the endearing
and fun captain red haired shanks Luffy
and shanks have known each other for a
number of years at this point indicated
by the teasing shanks does to Luffy and
the rapport they both seemed to share
for each other Luffy desperately wants
to be a pirate but concerned for his
safety and considering he can swim
captain shanks consistently refuses in a
variety of different means suddenly
however some thugs roll up to the bar
and begin stirring up some trouble
leading to a bottle of alcohol shanks
had offered in good faith being smashed
over his head shanks elects to do
nothing about this and the group of
thugs who leaves the tavern angry this
all takes place as Luffy was eating
right next to him at the bar and unable
to understand that shanks chose not to
fight for the sake of peace Luffy
becomes incredibly disillusioned at
shanks as actions about to walk off in a
huff they discover that the fruit Luffy
had eaten happened to be some of the
treasure they had brought home a magical
devil fruit that now gave him the
ability to stretch his limbs with one
major drawback he is now cursed to never
be able to swim not exactly ideal some
time passes on the next day Luffy fine
alone in the tavern once again shanks is
leaving for good this time and Luffy is
not going to see him off he still
considers him a coward for not standing
up for himself but now's his chance to
restore order to the universe because
that bully rolls up to the bar once
again the scene switches to the tavern
lady looking for help as luffy receives
a massive beating at the hands of this
thug leader by the name of he gue may
the bear and despite Luffy's unwavering
tenacity he's being beaten to a pulp
things are looking dire but then a gun
gets held up two shanks as head by one
of the thugs this leads to his crew
immediately taking action and the quick
fashion with which shanks takes care of
these vile individuals is a wonderfully
cathartic however in the chaos higuma
had made off with Luffy to the harbor in
an attempt to drown him things are never
as straightforward as this though and as
fast as you can blink a sea monster
erupts from the depths beneath eating
Akuma and the boat itself launching
Luffy into the ocean where he finds
himself once again saved by shanks who
in the process of saving him from this
sea monster loses his arm feeling
terrible about it Luffy asks what about
your arm shanks responds it's a small
price to pay it's just an arm I'm glad
you're okay
Luffy vows to be king of the Pirates and
shanks gives him his hat a hat that he
says means a lot to him he asks him to
please return it to him someday when
he's become a great pirate and it's this
brave individual in shanks and his token
to remember him by that influences the
rest of luffy's life he's going to be
the king of the Pirates one day he will
return shanks his hat and he will make
his life worth the brave sacrifice
shanks made for him by finding the
legendary treasure no one has been able
to find gold Rogers one piece what a
character introduction and what an
opening for this story I sincerely loved
it following these events there's a bit
of a time skip where we catch up with
Luffy ten years later he's grown up
considerably and is far more comfortable
now with his rubber man powers and just
as fun as ever he ventures into the
ocean completely unprepared considering
he has no idea how to navigate he can
swim and he has no destination other
than to find and recruit crewmembers for
his ship which let I remind you he
doesn't have yet effectively he has
nothing and is starting with only his
abilities and positive attitude
things quickly however take a turn for
the worst as they do in one piece when
we see Luffy sucked into a whirlpool
before caught into a young Kevin boy
called Kobe working under the lady
pirate iron mace Alvida he hates working
for her and in the middle of bringing a
barrel that had washed up onto the beach
back to base Luffy explodes from it and
together Kobe helps Luffy navigate to
where he needs to go and Luffy helps
liberate this young man from the
servitude he despises to help him
realize his dream of working for the
Navy together they overthrow the lady
captain La Veta commandeer a dinghy and
make headway for a nearby naval base
wherein luffy expresses interest
assuming he's a good guy in recruiting a
highly infamous and reputable pirate
hunter that goes by the name of Zorro
without much delay they arrive at the
naval base and find Zorro held captive
tied to a stake starving himself in a
yard the design of this character is I
think fantastic at a glance you can
immediately tell what sort of character
this guy is and the personality he
possesses and when thinking back over
this series so far
Oda has put a ton of care into his
designs for the characters if someone is
vain and nasty he makes them incredibly
ugly if someone is scared and unassuming
he emphasizes that feature and in the
case of Zorro this guy is confident and
damn cool within moments of meeting this
character we are also introduced to the
naval captain's son helmeppo and
incredibly selfish cowardly an
irredeemable character who provides us
our window into the naval bases corrupt
leadership situation under the rule of
the tyrannical captain Morgan who is
nothing like his son through flashbacks
we learn what Zorro has been fighting
and searching for a promise he made to
his one-time childhood rival to become
the greatest swordsman in all the world
before they died despite having an
intimidating reputation across the area
the entire reason Zorro is tied up in
the first place is for protecting a
young girl from Captain Morgan son's
attack dogs Luffy decides he likes the
cut of xaro's jib and asks him to be
part of his pirate crew however he
quickly declines saying that he has
plans of his own going on to explain the
helm fo said he only has to survive one
month for his freedom Luffy doesn't like
this but has to accept his decision
before heading down to the village where
he learns from he'll nepo himself that
sora will be executed very soon enraged
by this news Luffy clobbers the
obnoxious power leading to helmeppo
reporting Luffy to his father
the
and imposing Captain Morgan witness news
Luffy immediately runs and tries to free
Zorro but Zorro is reluctant to believe
taking the initiative Luffy then begins
searching for zoro's famous weapon the
sword while he's searching Coby reveals
to Zorro that the Navy have no intention
of releasing him and that he's up for
execution very soon Coby tries to free
him but it's too late
Morgan has arrived with his firing squad
who opened fire on the two of them
thankfully and surprisingly falling from
the sky comes Luffy who using his
amazing rubberband powers blocks all the
bullets and also returns the count'em
three swords of belonging to Zorro this
guy fights with three swords no big deal
together they team up to fight and
overthrow the evil Captain Morgan
retained the Navy to its former glory
Coby stays behind to follow his dream of
becoming a naval officer and Zorro
decides to join Luffy's crew in return
for saving his life
still vowing to be the greatest
swordsman to have ever lived while also
continuing his pursuit of a particular
individual widely known as the greatest
swordsman in the world Orangetown arc
chapters 8 to 24 this story picks up
right after the events the last one as
Zorro and Luffy float around starving
because no ether can navigate and
neither have food it seems that is until
they see a bird Luffy jumps up to catch
it but soon realizes that this bird is
much much bigger than he first
anticipated and thus it carries him away
until he reaches orange town where he
falls into the life of a pirate thief
called Nami in the middle of running
away from some pirates she swindled out
of a very valuable item a map to the
Grand Line a secret but very dangerous
area of the world that presumably is
filled with unspeakable riches and
perhaps might even be the location of
gold Rogers legendary treasure
while this is all happening Zorro
discovers three pirates marooned on a
defunct boat floating in the middle of
open ocean
they explained that this random girl
pretended to be starving and desperate
to lure them in and when the moment
presented itself
she stole their boat and treasure Zhora
decides to help them out and brings them
back to their base on orange town they
explained that they are part of a
notorious pirate crew led by the fabled
pirate captain believe the clown who is
easily the best design villain we have
seen so far I absolutely adore him
anyways after taking
refuge from the pursuing pirates in an
abandoned home on the island Nami
explains to Luffy that she specializes
in robbing pirates and that this buggy
the clown is not someone to take lightly
he's terrorized this town with monstrous
cannons and destruction to the point
it's almost being completely deserted
and legend has it he also has mysterious
powers
apparently the townspeople are after
moving a distance away to avoid these
pirate activities - Nami explains that
she hates pirates and that when she gets
100 million berries which I assume as
their currency she would by quote a
certain village and after learning of
this and her ability to navigate
effectively on the open water Luffy is
excited to ask her to be part of his
pirate crew she immediately declined so
ever and reveals that she had no idea
that Luffy was in fact a pirate this
exchange between the two characters of
how they came to meet up is full of
character and delivers exposition for
the respective situations fine enough
but at this point in my read-through I
became very annoyed at a particular
passion I began to notice Oda seems to
have a particular writing quirk during
this period of the story where he will
naturally explain the goals the plan and
the motivations of a particular
circumstance and that is all vital
information for the reader or viewer to
understand and to be perfectly honest he
delivers it rather well but he does this
thing where he either has Luffy say he
doesn't understand or wasn't listening
leading to that plan once again being
repeated in much simpler terms
anticipating that may be a reader wasn't
listening it honestly didn't bother me
the first time I saw it but it's
starting to become a trend I think it
shows a lack of confidence in either his
writing or the readers ability to
understand his writing honestly comes
off as a little clunky to me in addition
to that he seems to love this sort of
panel structure it's funny when it's
used sparingly but man does he use this
framing and gag a lot in the story early
on was in the first 10 chapters he must
have used the dozens and dozens of times
but anyways back to the story seeing an
opportunity to leverage Luffy's
innocence for her own personal gain she
agrees to be Lupe's navigator on the
condition he helps her with buggy the
clam she is of course lying Luffy
immediately agrees but once they arrive
she ties him up with the Rope she always
seems to carry with her and offers him
off to Bucky explaining that he was her
boss before expressing an interest in
joining his crew instead these are all
of course lies to create an opportunity
to nab his
I honestly love Nami as a character she
feels very believable and utilizes all
of her strengths to achieve what she
wants she might be my favorite as the
scene progresses Luffy is thrown into a
cage and Nami is left into Bucky the
clown's pirate crew
while all of that is happening Zorro
lands on the shore of orange town with
the three Pirates he saved and together
they lead him to buggy's hideout as
things progress back at the hideout
however it soon becomes obvious that
buggy is going to take luffy's life this
isn't at all what Nami wanted and when
forced to make the decision to prove her
loyalty by firing a cannon to wipe him
off the face of the earth she declines
and begins fighting this isn't at all
what she thought would happen and she's
not going to become what she hates
things admittedly are looking pretty bad
but that's when okay that was awesome
but unfortunately buggies mysterious
powers alluded to earlier came from
consuming a similar devil fruit - what
Luffy did and so he has the ability to
disassemble and reassemble himself due
to this unexpected trait Zorro lowers
his guard long enough to sustain a
serious injury outnumbered trapped and
now gravely injured Luffy and Zara
quickly come up with a plan of escape
they point the candidate the group of
pirates and when it fires Zorro lifts
the cage housing Luffy to safety a
righteous bravery and selflessness by
surprise and what follows this was
honestly incredibly unexpected in a
brilliant way as Luffy and Zorro are
trying to figure out their next move
after having escaped they notice a dog
barking at the front of a pet food store
the mayor of the town would have the
last residents still in the town
explains that now the dogs master is
deceased and that his last order was for
his loyal Popper to protect the store
while he was gone
- that little dog that building is his
treasure what a beautiful metaphor and
perfectly fitting for one piece I've
only briefly touched on this particular
story thread here but the story behind
it actually made me cry I'm a sucker for
a loyal dog story and this was beautiful
and tragic all at the same time I've
never in my life cried while reading
before and one piece certainly brought
an end to that streak the remainder of
this arc is pretty much its third act
buggy unleashes his subordinates to find
and deal with Luffy and Zorro the latter
of whom has managed to find refuge with
the mayor of the town one of buggy's
lackeys happens to be a lion tamer to
keep up with the circus theme and
despite the little
best efforts to protect the only thing
left behind by his now deceased master
the tamer and his lion beat the living
daylights out of the dog leaving behind
nothing but a burning building
I need Luffy to bring justice to the
world now and bring justice to the world
he most certainly does but unfortunately
the damage has already been done
all thus left is ash and a single box of
food Luffy sits next to the little dog
and gives that to him Nami realizes in
that moment that Luffy had fought the
lion specifically for that little dog
throughout this arc the through-line has
been the light in which Nami views Luffy
while he having nothing to prove to her
specifically by simply being who he is
Luffy demonstrates enough to dissuade or
at the very least inject some doubt into
her perceived notions about the young
pirate the remainder of the AK is full
of more selfless sacrifice and rescue
mainly by Luffy who protects the town's
mayor with the help of Nami and a
beautiful callback to the fact that she
always carries rope with her ultimately
leading to buggy's defeat oh and there's
this scene where Luffy kicks the
disembodied groin of buggy to stop his
other body parts in their tracks which I
honestly found a little more funny than
I probably should have and to cap it all
off when the townspeople finally return
to chase off the Pirates Luffy and Xaro
are forced to flee but the little dog
who was was aggressive towards these
guys now stands to valiantly protect
them from the mob what a beautifully
crafted little story about personal
treasure prejudice and trust I love it
and on top of all of that despite not
fully committing to the crew Luffy and
Xaro now have a navigator in Nami who's
agreed to travel to the Grand Line
together as it's both a worthwhile
endeavor and mutually beneficial syrup
village arc chapters 24 to 41 the
portion of the show that I've reviewed
this fire has clearly been in a casual
recruitment phase wherein Luffy
assembles his ragtag group of
personalities to accompany him on his
adventures around the world and this arc
is no different in the same way the last
couple stories centered around the
recruitment of Zorro and Nami this one
centers around the recruitment of a
slingshot wielding troublesome town liar
named goofs up and unfortunately of the
arcs I'm covering in this video I
enjoyed this one the least but that's
not to say this wasn't good or that I
didn't enjoy it it's probably more to do
with the fact it's sandwiched between
the last act which I thought was great
and the next one which is really really
good but I'm getting a little ahead of
myself here this particular story
continues as Nami Zorro and Luffy are
sailing along the sea in their tiny boat
they all notice the distinct lack of
provisions as well as the inadequate
sailing vessel they possess and so
touching down on land they endeavor to
find a remedy to all of these issues
this is when we cut to the man of the
hour
ooh sup who seems to enjoy pretending
that pirates are attacking his town in
what seems to be an attempt to rile up
trouble in his neighborhood if it's
starting to sound like a variation and
the boy who cried wolf story that's
because it is but with a distinct pirate
twist you see despite being a notorious
liar he also has a small group of
children that act as his pirate crew but
upon seeing Luffy and the gang touched
down on the beach the children Bale
leading to sob eventually inviting the
gang for food there he explains a bit
about the town and the local affluent
residents owned by a sickly young orphan
named kya and it turns out Asaf has a
wonderful relationship with her despite
him not exactly being well-liked by the
village due to his lying the wonderful
stories he fabricates for the young
mistress kya makes her very happy
much to the dismay of her butler caja
door it's a strange name who at every
turn tries to dissuade kya from
interacting with the likes of OSA coming
to a head one day when who stop despite
being told not to travels to her window
to regain her once again with
fantastical stories of adventure and fun
while this is happening Luffy decides
that the best course of action would be
to ask hyah first ship himself because
that's what grown-ups do I guess if you
don't ask you won't receive however by
the time he arrives at the property Clea
door is reprimanding and belittling
loose opt for trespassing on her land
taking things too far by attacking who
stops personal character and his
father's legacy leading to some would
say a fair reaction of a sob punching
him in the face
storming off at the behest of kya who
got deeply upset at the violence while
this is all happening a character called
Jango who is heavily inspired by a
certain pop star let's see if you can
guess who by this subtle clue lore walks
down the road until he meets the three
young boys from ooh sobs crew revealing
that he's a sort of hypnotist meanwhile
Luffy catches up to you stop who has
decided to run to a secluded spot
overlooking the ocean there he tries to
console us off by letting him know that
he knew his father and considered him a
great men things are going rather
smoothly until they hear chatter from
down below on the beach
if Django the hypnotist from earlier and
I adore the butler while he is dropping
from above they overhear a sinister plot
that involves taking all of Caius family
fortune and ransacking the village it
turns out Clara doors real name is
captain Kuro a vicious and feared pirate
thought to have been sentenced to death
years ago in reality he has been playing
the long con in an attempt to start
afresh reputation disconnected from the
horrible things he's done so that he can
do more unspeakable things in the future
apparently the plan is to hypnotize kaya
and to have her sign over her family's
fortune and to sack the village the plan
is perfectly fine but the way it's
delivered felt pretty unnatural and sort
of clunky to me the questions from Jango
felt like they were for the benefit of
the viewer and reader and something he
should already have the answers to
himself in other words he shouldn't need
to ask about this also the odds of them
choosing the spot directly beneath where
oh soft and Luffy work was a bit too
coincidental for my taste in addition to
that super clear exposition we just
received we get Luffy saying that he
can't hear what's being said and Lusa
proceeds to break down the entire plot
for a second time and we have to read it
or listen to it true which I still find
pretty annoying but regardless once
Luffy is caught up he shouts down at
them to not do the bad thing and then
proceeds to faceplant falling from the
cliff to the ground below
captain kuru believes the boy to be dead
and firuze up to not have a chance at
convincing anyone of anything
despite this who sub tries to make haste
by warning the village that pirates are
coming in the morning and they naturally
don't believe him shock horror instead
of cooperating he gets chased off for
his trouble and flees to kaya's where he
tries to warn her and take her to safety
she refuses shock horror out of time and
now out of options
who's up is left to defend the village
alone that is until Luffy and the gang
offered their services and while the
actions supplied for this section
doesn't have disembodied nut shots on
clothes
it does have captain
who has big old cat claws and is by far
the most ruthless individual we've ever
met in the story so far he takes himself
very seriously and I felt a different
tension while reading his character we
get some good stuff from Nami and Zorro
too but I think my favorite aspect of
this series so far is while it has its
obvious shortcomings to me they're
easily forgiven and alongside them Oda
sprinkles moments that remind me that he
knows exactly what he's doing when it
comes to storytelling for instance
during a section where Luffy is fighting
clad or or captain Kuro your choice
boosts up is being carried into the
forest by Zorro chasing after the
Michael Jackson inspired pirate who is
chasing after the three young boys and a
young girl kaya he sets it up such that
we are waiting for OSAP and Zara to
arrive to save the day and so while I am
watching the kids struggle and set up
counter-attacks against Jango I am very
much waiting for Zhou reduce up to
arrive Oda knows this and so when they
do arrive he sneaks in a counter-attack
by the little kids I wasn't expecting
because I was too busy waiting for Zorro
and goose' it's these subtle check off
gun moments that I am honestly most
impressed by it's a very basic swerve to
help deliver a conclusion to a fight
scene but you'd be surprised how many
don't use it as effectively or as
regularly as oded us the fights during
this section of the story are also
really well done I very much enjoyed the
colorful cast and crew members under
captain Kuro and the challenges that
they provided Luffy and the gang on top
of that I thought the fights were served
pretty well by the setting of the battle
a short front and narrow slipways
surrounded by forests it's a nice little
setup
I don't think captain cool was as fun as
captain buggy was but he offered
something completely different and as I
pointed out earlier was far more serious
in and of itself which was very valuable
in the end Luffy overpowers and
outmaneuvers the crazed captain Kuro
leading to stop joining Luffy's crew he
promises to one day return to kya and to
regain her with tons of true and
fantastical stories as a thanks for
their valiant efforts kya supplies them
with their very own ship to sail across
the sea complete with provisions we also
get one last tidbit of information about
ourselves past also regarding his mother
and the origin behind why he cries
pirate and this is an aspect of this
series I've been very much impressed by
and that's its willingness and
determination to make you care about
these individual characters Luffy
ultimately recruits into his misfit band
of would-be Pirates
through their respective debut arcs
whether it be aloof
himself Zorro Nami ro sup any and every
character Oda adds to the group is
thoroughly explored and understood by
the reader or viewer first and foremost
before they join the ranks so in terms
of character writing I'm very happy with
what I'm seeing so far and I can't wait
to see who's joining the crew next the
barity arc chapters 42 to 68 this will
be the final act I'll be discussing
today and of the acts I have read
through this was by far my favorites
but before I start I should say that
this arc was so insanely dense with
stuff happening that I've had to omit
certain parts and quickly go over others
to make room for what I thought to be
the most important aspects of this story
so let's jump in while playing with the
new Canon on this fancy new ship they've
acquired the crew end up discovering two
individuals
yosaku and Johnny the former of which
was suffering the effects of scurvy this
incident brings to the crews attention
that they require a cook aboard this
ship
they eventually come across an ocean
faring restaurant called Barrett II
after they accidentally deflect the
cannonball onto the premises causing a
lot of damage leading to Luffy having to
pay off the damages by means of working
in their kitchens inside this restaurant
we get introduced to the various wacky
and oftentimes aggressive cooking staff
aboard the Barret 8 as well as the head
chef Zeff a former pirate that has
settled down as the owner of this
restaurant and a particularly
interesting character named Sanji
another chef working at the restaurant
who happens to be a very capable fighter
to sporting what I believe to be a
genius character design and personally
he has a dream of one day finding the
all blue sea however he remains
committed to the kitchen and the
restaurant for reasons he refuses to
share and despite his abrasive
relationships with the majority of the
staff working there insists on remaining
in the barity he's also a sucker for the
ladies so I hope that gag doesn't get
old too fast
yikes once everyone settles down someone
bursts through the door of the main
dining hall announcing that the captive
has escaped followed by that man doing
the falldown dance and the captive
rowing up to a chair demanding to be fed
this man's name is Keane and he gets
pulverized and reprimanded for these
actions by the restaurant staff however
not liking the thought of anyone going
hungry Sanji in privacy gives gain food
for free apparently this is a trend with
him and
actually Luffy wants him to join his
crew as their cook but he refuses citing
that he has his own reasons to stay
during this conversation Luffy explains
that he has plans of traveling to the
Grand Line which Peaks Keens interest
leading him to warn Luffy never to go
there after this generosity from Sanji
Gein ends up leaving but quickly returns
bursting through the door with the most
feared man in all of East blue on his
shoulder the head honcho of an armada
consisting of 50 ships the feared Don
Creek however now on the verge of death
his fleet almost gone and his flagship
in tatters he's here but only after
barely managing to return from a seven
day trip to the Grand Line during a
massive storm he gets down onto his pens
and needs begging for food and pity and
eventually Sanji shows mercy and feeds
him much to the chagrin of the fellow
cooks after receiving this food and
regaining his strength Krieg immediately
beats Sanji to the floor
there's nothing likeable about that and
it's honestly a great villain
introduction but he's not done much like
he was his crew is in a shambles and in
desperate need of food he wants to feed
them and essentially take over the
barity restaurant ship he also expresses
and reveals that Chef Zeff was once an
incredible pirate who managed to
successfully navigate and survive on the
grand line for a year unable to do that
himself Krieg wants that logbook of zebb
Strip to help him on his next trip on
the grind line this is great because all
the people we've met on this journey up
to this point have brought up the grand
line in one form or another towards the
very beginning it was a place only
suicidal fools travel to then bogey had
planned to go there with his map Luffy
got the map and now we've met her very
first person to have actually gone there
and returned and he barely made it out
alive this is a wonderful progression in
villains that is measured in the goal we
are working towards the grand line
excellent writing jean is honestly taken
aback by all of this and apologizes
profusely for bringing this upon after
one at the parity but Zeff the head chef
gives Krieg food for his crew much once
again to the chagrin of his various
employees he doesn't want them to go
hungry either don krieg then leaves to
feed his crew while the rest of the
staff aboard the paraty consisting
largely of fighters and ruffians begin
readying themselves for battle however
just as soon as they hear Krieg's army
of crewmen come
a massive attack slices the flagship of
don krieg in half completely taken it
back by the thunderous sound they run
outside to find yosaku and Johnny in the
water as well as the destroyed ship of
Krieg's the two explained that they are
in the water not because of what just
happened but because Nami threw them out
and made off with their ship eyeballing
a certain bounty list in their
possession naturally everyone is shocked
by this and what's worse is that they
have someone much much more dangerous
than Don Creek to contend with right now
slowly approaching their ship is a
shadowy figure that Zeff recognizes Jean
explains that while they were on the
Grand Line on the seventh day Krieg's
Armada was destroyed by one man and that
if that massive storm hadn't come their
flagship would most definitely have
fallen - apparently an individual that
goes by the moniker Hawkeye is
responsible for creeks current state of
affairs and it just so happens that this
is the same someone Zorro has been
looking for for many many years first of
all I want to say I friggin love Hawkeye
his design here just had to get that out
and his introduction is honestly
spectacular it's explained that he's
been chasing down creeks crew for pretty
much fun they quickly tried to shoot him
but Zora pops up from the crowd and says
that bullets won't work that he'll
simply deflect them he also announces
that he's been looking for him that he
wants to be the best and that if he
wants some fun
Hawkeye can fight him pointing his sword
directly towards the greatest swordsman
in the world Hawkeye in response to this
asks where he gets his courage to point
this sword does it come from confidence
or ignorance Zorro succinctly replies it
comes from ambition and a promise I made
to a friend incredible line we then
switched scenes and get a glimpse of
Nami sailing away crying hoping that
they'll meet again she laments I can't
wait to be free there are so many moving
parts to this story and I have no idea
what's going on I honestly love it I
don't know what to expect
accepting his challenge Hawkeye whips
out a tiny knife saying I'm not the kind
of fool who hunts rabbits with a cannon
upon reading that line my mouth fell
open and I had to run around the house
showing people that line it might very
well be the most Chad thing I've ever
read in my life he explains that the red
line and grand line split the Seas into
four the east the south the north and
the west blue going on to say that east
their area is the Tama sub the four C's
and that tiny knife is the smallest
blade he has speaking directly at Zorro
he says it's time you learned how big
the world is they begin to fight but
Zorro is easily outclassed he thinks
back to the promise he made to that
friend when he was a kid to be the
greatest swordsman Hawkeye stabs him in
the chest
Zorro still refuses to retreat to safety
because turret Reese means defeat and
he'd rather die than to accept that in
doing this he earns Hawkeye's respect
needing him to bring out his best weapon
a large black sword Zora tries again to
defend himself but his swords shattered
now completely unarmed he stands facing
the greatest swordsman alive leaving
himself now completely open as a wound
to the back is a disgrace to a great
swordsman Hawkeye recognizes his efforts
slashing him to the floor however
impressed by his honor and bravery
Hawkeye allows aura to live he wants him
to travel far and wide to hone his
skills and to try to defeat him once
again he thanks Luffy for allowing his
crewmate to fight his fight without
getting involved asking him what his
dream is Luffy responds to be the Pirate
King
Hawkeye says that's even more perilous
than trying to surpass me Zorro lifts
his sword to the air and vows to never
lose again Luffy is honestly happy to
see him move and to see that hunger
swell within him once again
I love haka as a character his design is
exceptional and honestly perfect for the
setting and the ship he sails directly
reflects his philosophy he's not brash
or a show-off
he's just phenomenal and recognizes true
ambition and dedication in others and
with that we finally gotten her first
taste of what lies beyond the safety of
the east blue sea after this altercation
Jonny Yousef yo suka and a beatin of
Zorro decide to follow after the trail
of nummies commandeered ship Luffy on
the other hand has elected to stay and
thus we'll have to find them after he
finishes dealing with business here once
again after a series of creative and
unusual character introductions and
fights involving don krieg his pirate
crew and a new character called
invincible pearl who also works under
don krieg luffy and Sanji finally start
to gain the upper hand when
Oh des catches me once again completely
off-guard with Jeanne taking action like
this demonstrating to me that he knows
exactly what he's doing as a Monica when
it comes to creating surprise and
tension in the scene jeans been seen
largely as a voice of reason
amidst the ranks of don krieg and so we
or at the very least I put him to the
back of my head as someone who's not
really a threat but he is still a pirate
working for Krieg so this makes complete
sense for him to get involved here in
this situation I'm honestly loving this
he demands Sanji to leave the ship but
he refuses invincible Perl gathers
himself again and attacks Sanjay who is
now extremely beaten still refuses to
leave citing that he's taken everything
from that old man referring to the
owners F he's taken his strength and his
dreams swearing that he won't let
anything else be lost
hearing this creaks forces once again
blindside Sanjay landing a massive
attack on the young man we are then
greeted by a flashback from Sandy's past
taking us nine years prior to the events
of today as Sanjay as a young cooks
apprentice on a ship he's discussing his
dream of finding the all blue sea a
legendary place that might not exist and
is said to have the best fish to cook
suddenly their ship gets pillaged by
captain's f's crew on the return from
the grand line however things suddenly
take a turn for the worst asan G is
dragged overboard as the store outside
rages on without hesitation Zeff jumps
overboard to save him he never had any
intention of taking anyone's life just
to steal some food and valuables the
storm begins to worsen and we cut to a
small island that the two have washed up
on SEF suspects his ship was destroyed
and so they should both go to either
side of the island to keep an eye out
for passing vessels he places a small
sack of food in front of Sanjay
explained that this is his bag of food
and that this larger bag is his because
he's bigger and therefore needs it but
despite having this bag we later see
zeph in isolation on the other side of
the island taking action into his own
heads beating his own foot with a rock
Sanjay still deeply spiteful of Zef but
now on his own side reckons with proper
rationing the supply can last twenty
days unfortunately days twenty five
thirty fifty and seventy passed by with
only one opportunity presenting itself
during impossible weather conditions at
this stage about to starve
Sanji decides to go to the other side to
see if Zeff
situation is any better he took more
food after all and he sees the bag
hasn't changed size once Angie cuts the
bag though it's revealed that it's full
of treasure and no food Sanji then
approaches f to find that he's nothing
but skin and bone missing the lower half
of his leg he cut her off to survive
just that little bit longer given all of
the food to Sanjay Zef remarks that he
liked Sanji because he had the same
dream he had to find the all blue on day
85 the tuber rescued Zeff saved Sanji's
life after this the flashback ends and
Sanji stands up and declares that he
will defend him with his life and repay
his debt the final fight that takes
place utilizes all the strengths and
weaknesses of both the villains and the
heroes feeding into dramatic character
choices demonstrations failings and
successes to say that this is the
biggest and most climactic fight
attempted by one piece so far would be
an understatement and if the runtime of
this video is any indication my ability
to break down the nuance and style this
particular hour Grace's us with is
clearly lacking and that's not even to
mention the choreography angles and
framing that this final section of the
story implements if I were to fully
break down everything that this arc had
to offer this video would probably be
about two hours long and I wouldn't be
able to release a follow-up for a month
so with that in mind let's try to wrap
things up with tenacity griten style
both Sanjay and Luffy defeat the forces
of don krieg later getting carried off
by Keane who thanks both Luffy and Sanji
for having saved and spared his life the
following day after the events Luffy
wakes up and both he and Sanji make
their way to the dining hall to have
some grub the soup prepared by Sanjay
has everyone in the building gagging
thrown on the floor and berating Sanjay
for having made it Sanji naturally gets
extremely angry at everyone for treating
him like this he confronts chef Zephyr
bun - leading to the chef punching him
in the face you'll never be able to cook
like me I've cooked on all the oceans of
the world he says Sanjay then storms off
and that's when everyone explains that
they've done all this to try and
convince Anji to leave with Luffy to
follow his dream sitting outside the
doorway Sanji hears all of this
transpire Luffy says that he won't take
sandy with him that he needs to make
that decision on his own listen to all
of this seemingly at random Sanji gets
hit by a shark from the sky crashing in
to the room where luffy and the others
are in the mouth of this shark is osika
who was last seen in the boat with who
sobs or oh and his brother johnny
explaining that if his calculations are
correct
he can take luffy to where nami was
heading they decide to go but before
they do
Sanji says that he wants to join them on
their adventure and follow his dreams
luffy rejoices and begins making his way
out but before following the others
Sanji addresses everyone and lets them
know that he's aware that the all
pretended not to like his soup as he
gets ready
Sanji reflects on his life up until now
how they opened the shop together how
they came to employ all these colorful
characters and all the time he stood up
for Zeff asaji makes his way down the
deck towards the small boat where Luffy
is waiting everyone is there to watch
him leave the two main chefs tried to
attack him but they had no chance no one
else makes a single sound no goodbyes or
anything Luffy asks if he wanted to say
goodbye but Sanji says no and that's
when chef Stef says hey Sanji keep your
feet dry
a beautifully subtle call back to how he
saved him when he fell overboard as a
child hearing this Sanji breaks down
crying and shouts out that he owes his
life to Zef and that he will miss them
all the rest shut the same back to him
and it's a beautiful way to cap off this
arc and this video the level of
attention to detail and commitment to
follow oda is having with this story
borders on pathological levels of
dedication for instance I didn't even
mention yet or notice for that matter up
until chapter 39 that the pieces of
cover art that he does for each
individual chapter actually tells their
own mini story the story being buggy the
clown's escapades after meeting Luffy
for the first time it's hilarious and he
literally almost missed it
I think what I might love most of it I
each hero oda can be best summed up by
this piece of information
my editor shared with me about him from
a very early age he had a comprehensive
grasp of this story including designs
for characters Islands cultures and
political factions and perhaps my most
favorite aspect of him and this story is
that from the moment he started he's
known exactly how he's going to finish
it and now over 20 years into the future
he still has yet to end this mammoth of
a journey
I can't wait to continue along on this
spectacular adventure but something
tells me I haven't seen
anything yet and that my adventure is
only just beginning I've been totally
not mark thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you all next week
[Music]